[Music]
so it's with great pleasure today that i
cancelled jon stewart now jon stewart
actually has a show which streams on
apple tv and which generates enthusiasm
and public interest about on the level
with a wnba game
if you're like the average person you
probably didn't even know that the show
existed the last you heard from stuart
was probably several months ago when he
went viral for criticizing some aspects
of the mainstream covet narrative it was
last year and he earned many high fives
and back slaps from the right for this
moment of lucidity oh that jon stewart
conservative said he's not he's not woke
like other liberals he's one of the good
ones you know
this is a familiar process someone on
the left says something mildly sane and
then is immediately valorized by the
right as a champion of truth and common
sense he's baptized usually against his
will as an honorary conservative even as
99.9 of his worldview still remains
firmly planted on the left end of the
political spectrum
the next step in the process is
inevitable the newly christened
conservative hero proceeds shortly after
this fleeting episode of rationality
to go back to far left talking points
and then he is once again demonized by
the same conservatives who two seconds
before we're ready to canonize him
around and around we go nothing ever
changes on that note here is jon stewart
on his apple tv show talking to his
viewers about or rather to his viewer
about the problem with white people
listen
for however sincerely we want to reckon
and listen
the truth is america has always
prioritized white comfort over black
survival
black people have had to fight so hard
for equality
that they've been irreparably set back
in the pursuit of equity
and any real attempt to uh rep rep
repair
a ton of
that damage
reparation
sets off white peoples they're coming
for our alarm
which we would know ourselves
had we actually been listening my
feeling is white people
have a very very serious
problem
and they should start thinking
about what they can do about it
take me out of it
understood
so what you can't see in that video
because it's just out of frame is
ebermex candy standing there with a gun
pointed right at jon stewart at least i
assume that's what's happening because
the whole thing has the look sound and
feel of one of those taliban hostage
videos only it's worse than that because
the taliban to my knowledge doesn't
usually castrate the hostage before
filming the video
stuart on the other hand sits there like
a docile gelding head bowed meekly
whispering understood
after a black woman declares that
everything is the fault of white people
later in the episode stuart uh brought
on a panel of fellow self-hating whites
to talk about uh some more about how
awful white people are there was one man
involved in the conversation andrew
sullivan who had the gumption to suggest
that perhaps white people are not
necessarily spawns of satan and that
maybe in fact there might even be some
good things about america in american
history and white people
these outrageous claims were dutifully
shouted down by stewart and the other
panelists listen to that
you're not living on the same planet we
are
honestly
i really don't think you are if you are
not living
i think you are not living in the planet
most americans are which is why this
kind of extremism
right this anti-white extremism yes is
losing
popular support is creating a backlash
is going to elect republicans and undo a
lot of the good you think you're doing
this is what happens when you don't talk
about it this is what happens when white
people don't talk about it is you have
racist dog whistle tropes like this that
actually perpetuate and perpetuate and
perfect
so i am i i and i did not come on this
on this show to sit here and argue with
another white man that's one of the
reasons that we don't even engage with
white men at race to dinner
you know because quite honestly if white
men were going to do something about
racism you had 400 years yeah
[Applause]
oh she's not going to engage with white
men
she went on a white man's show
to sit on a panel with white men
but she doesn't want to talk to white
men
she hates white men she despises them
doesn't even think that they should be
able to speak and she feels comfortable
vocalizing all of this bigotry because
she expects that she'll be applauded for
it and she was but remember
all of our systems are racist against
black people even though the only group
of people you can actually be openly
racist against are white people
especially white men makes total sense
if you're brain damaged or have single
digit iq which is precisely demographic
that critical race theory appeals to the
most
now
the angry portly woman there with the
bad haircut says that
white men should have already done
something about racism we have 400 years
she says
to which you might point out that it was
largely white men who abolished slavery
um white men didn't invent slavery but
they did abolish it white men in fact
are responsible for many of the best
things about our civilization that's
just a fact white men have been busy you
know
inventing modern science and building
skyscrapers and fighting and dying in
our wars and defeating the nazis
creating modern medicine inventing cars
electricity space travel antibiotics
writing the greatest novels and plays
and poems in history that's what white
men have been up to
but they're not worthy of even speaking
to the bitter cat lady on the jon
stewart panel she turns up her nose at
the whole group be gone she says
well okay maybe we'll go but you better
hope we don't take all our stuff with us
on the way out the door because you're
not gonna be left with much if we do
but hold on a second she said that uh
white men had 400 years to do something
about racism
why 400 years specifically i mean what
about and what about everybody else on
earth
what was everyone else doing about
racism
who exactly was fighting against racism
400 years ago
well she says 400 years ago because
she's a mindless disciple of the 1619
project and she believes that racism was
invented around that time and that it
was white people who invented it and
only white people ever engaged in it
in reality of course racism has existed
in the human species everywhere on earth
in every population everywhere since the
dawn of civilization racism is just one
form of tribalism
it's a form of tribalism that still
exists in the world today in fact and
can be found in much more virulent and
violent forms in the parts of the world
where white people are least present
it's not just that there is racial and
ethnic tribalism in africa and asia too
it's that there's a whole hell of a lot
more of it in those regions of the world
and it comes in a far more brutal
package
now going back in history i asked
earlier
who exactly was fighting against racism
400 years ago i'm not claiming that
white men were but and they weren't but
but who was
well the answer is nobody
not a soul on earth back in those
days the idea that all people should be
treated equally regardless of how they
look or where they're from is an idea
that simply did not exist
anywhere in the world 400 years ago
that idea had to be thought of and
codified into law and guess who thought
of it
that's right white men
now granted the white men who came up
with the concept did not actually apply
it consistently because when it came
down to it they shared the flaws that
were ubiquitous in almost all human
beings on earth at that time
but they certainly set the stage for
racial equality under the law
they put the framework in place
i'd say that's a pretty significant
achievement
even if it doesn't impress the panelists
on jon stewart's show or jon stewart
himself
but who really cares because anyway
jon stewart is today cancelled
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated